hi everyone thank you for joining and uh
we're very happy to have uh dr catherine
briddick from
the refugee study center uh the
department of international development
at the university of oxford in the uk
joining us uh thank you for joining us
uh virtually dr brady and we'll um you
know we've had a
more than a year-long
seminar series and today we'll explore a
new aspect of this which is the
intersection of gender and and migration
so we're very excited to uh
to hear you speak so not only will we
get this in on um
you know in
in on in live today we'll we're also
recording the event we'll put it up on
our webpage so others will have access
to it offline as well
so okay i'll turn it over to you
thank you very much for the invitation
uh to speak today after what has been i
think for many of us a kind of a
demanding term i appreciate there are
many calls on your time um so thank you
very much for listening to me talk today
about cedaw and discrimination
experienced in the context of migration
control
so women are disadvantaged by migration
law in a number of different ways
disadvantage can be the product of rules
or practices which explicitly treat
women less favorably than men so for
example rules that prevent women's
emigration
usually however gender disadvantage
flows from rules which appear on their
face to be gender or sex neutral but
which actually disadvantage women or
particular groups of women
this disadvantage can be expressive or
material it can entail stereotyping the
devaluation of women's work loss of
employment or other opportunities and
the confinement of women to certain
roles in relationship
it can increase women's risk of
experiencing violence and it can simply
be violent
now such rules and practices can be
characterized as being unlawfully
discriminatory by reference to national
equality legislation or international
law
over the next 45 minutes i'm going to be
presenting research which examines the
application of the un convention on the
elimination of all forms of
discrimination against women
cedaw and i'm going to be asking two
broad questions
firstly what does cedaw's general
prohibition of discrimination entail in
the context of migration control
put another way what detailed
obligations do states assume under cedar
in relation to their migration control
functions and second when rules and
practices are challenged on the grounds
of discrimination
what outcome do they have for the women
who bring those challenges
in the second part of the research then
i'm moving to look at the implementation
of the standards that the cedaw
committee has set and i do that by
reviewing individual complaints that are
brought under siegel's optional protocol
over a nine year period
as will hopefully be apparent this
seminar therefore is rooted in a legal
disciplinary approach to both
discrimination and migration law and i
appreciate that many of the people
joining me today are from a
multi-disciplinary program so if you
have any questions or comments and as we
go and please do ask them in the chat
and stop me um it's much better to
clarify a term or a concept and as i
unpack hopefully what will be my central
argument um and it should enable us to
have hopefully more fruitful exchange of
ideas um at the end of the presentation
so i'm going to be focusing as i said um
on cedaw
and i'm going to be examining the work
of the treaty body the human rights
treaty body and that oversees the
conventions implementation the cedaw
committee
so i'm going to do three things firstly
i'm going to explain what discrimination
against women is in international law
secondly i'm going to turn to to discuss
what the convention requires in the
migration control context and third i'm
going to examine the committee's
applications of the obligations it has
delineated to states
there are two parts of my argument
the first is that i'm going to identify
doctrinal and empirical shortcomings in
the committee's reasoning on when and
why
certain widespread migration control
practices are unlawfully discriminatory
and second when i turn to looking at
individual communications brought under
the conventions optional protocol i'm
going to reveal a particular kind of
responsibility deficit a deficit between
determination and application between
how the committee approaches migrant
women's rights in the abstract when
discharging its general interpretive
role and when it behaves and when
confronted with a particular rule or
practice that an individual alleges is
discriminatory
so turning to the first of these
um as maybe apparent from the slide i
have primary school aged children which
means i do a lot of coloring in
so um in front of you you have um the
article one um definition of
discrimination against women that's
found right at the outset of the cedaw
convention
and as you can see this is an
asymmetrical protection from
discrimination
um so unlike um sedorf sorry unlike surd
for example which prohibits which
defines and then prohibits any forms of
discrimination on the grounds of race
cedaw specifically protects women from
discrimination
and at first glance if we look at this
definition cedaw seems ideally placed to
respond to the discrimination that
migrant women may be subject to
article 1 encompasses both direct and
indirect discrimination
it may therefore be relied on to
challenge rules which are explicitly
disadvantageous to women and those which
negatively affect women or particular
groups of women even though they appear
to be gender neutral
and the wording that i have picked out
um
in
i think it is yellow any distinction um
exclusion or restriction which has the
effect or purpose of moving into green
um establishes an adverse effect whether
or not that is intentional as being the
definitions crucial criteria
the breadth of the definition and in
particular its reference
to language that refers to public life
so the prohibition of discrimination
that occurs in economic social cultural
civil um or any other field
enables the convention um to
be to normal essentially to provide a
role in the convention that includes
gender-based violence that is violence
that is directed against a woman because
she is a woman or which affects women
disproportionately
now states migration control practices
such as pushbacks for example may
involve violence or be violence but
there are other practices that states
engage in such as making people
destitute for example or prohibited
women from having recourse to certain
state services such as health care
these services may increase women's
vulnerability to the violence that's
perpetrated by non-state actors now the
cedaw committee's characterization as
gender-based violence as a form of
discrimination enables such rules and
practices to be challenged to be brought
within the power view of the convention
finally article 1 can be relied on to
reinforce and complement two legal
regimes which are crucial to
international migration but whose key
instruments fail to define or prohibit
sex or gender discrimination
the trafficking and international
protection regimes
the definition also requires states to
provide gender sensitive interpretations
of those instruments
now while the international covenant on
civil and political rights the iccpr
and the convention on the elimination of
all forms of racial discrimination cert
differentiate between citizens and
non-citizens the cedaw committee is
clear that the obligations of state
parties apply without discrimination to
both citizens and non-citizens including
refugees asylum seekers
migrant workers and stateless persons
within their territory or effective
control even if not situated within the
territory
states parties are responsible for all
their actions the committee opines and
whether or not the individual concerned
is in their territory
now the sea door committee yes
question so
who is in charge of enforcing these uh
uh
these articles
so the
enforcement
yes so the cedaw committee is the treaty
body responsible for monitoring the
application of the convention
now the cedaw committee um has two roles
so one is the world i mentioned earlier
it hears individual complaints so that's
where individuals can allege that for
example they have been discriminated
against contrary to article one of the
convention and the seed or committee
will adjudicate on that much like an
international court or tribunal although
it's not that
um but the sea door committee will also
review reports of states so states party
to cedaw have to produce information to
the committee every four or five years
to talk about how they've implemented
the convention in their domestic law and
there's also a role for civil society
there and pointing out or highlighting
gaps in states implementation of the
convention
um we might want to think about the sea
door committee as being a soft court so
it's not an international court or
tribunal like the inter-american court
for example and but it has this
monitoring and adjudicative role
and and how many states have signing
into
i mean this
i mean complying
or
this convention
so i think there are over a hundred
states parties to cedaw it's one of the
most um
widely
uh ratified of the conventions
um so
it's part of the international bill of
rights essentially it's part of the kind
of core
framework for dealing with
international human rights law and
international rights abuses the reason
why i'm sounding hesitant is because
while cedaw has a really important role
in international human rights law it's
also the most reserved treaty so what
that means is that states sign and
ratify the convention but they also
enter reservations to particular parts
of it which means that they try and
argue that either they shouldn't be
bound by a particular prevention
provision such as one concerned with
equality in marriage for example um all
that they have a particularly or
slightly different interpretation of it
so it's a convention that's ratified by
states across the world but it's also um
one of the the conventions that um
states try and take almost like a pick
and mix approach to they're highly
selective in the legal obligations they
assume
now the reason why um i've got this
quote on the slide in front of you is
because a number of human rights
instruments in international law
differentiate between the rights that
accrue to citizens and the rights that
accrue to migrants and cedaw takes a
different approach it takes a broad
approach to both its beneficiary group
and jurisdiction so the rights that it
provides should apply to women whether
they have a secure migration status in
the country that they are in or whether
they don't
and that's quite different and from
other international instruments
cedaw is also establishing here an
effects-based approach to jurisdiction
so it can protect or offers protection
to individuals from harm that crosses
state borders
so the provisional title of my talk um
today was when does migration law
discriminate
against women
and i mentioned that the first part of
the research was focusing on
working out what states obligations were
and under international human rights law
in relation to their migration control
functions
so article one of cedaw defines
discrimination against women and article
two of cedaw prohibits it
and the committee that monitors it the
treaty body that i must mentioned and
draws on article one and two to impune
as unlawfully discriminatory and number
of states migration control practices
now in a moment i'm going to talk to you
um about uh non-reformer the protection
that's offered to individuals who can't
be returned to their country of origin
because for example they face um serious
forms of discrimination or harm
including gender-based violence
but in an article for the american
journal of international law i go into a
lot more detail about the way that for
example and certain um migration control
practices which are widely used by
states for example detention or pushback
are impugned by the committee as
engaging its prohibition on
discrimination
a number of rules which are very
commonly found in for example british
and u.s immigration law are also
highlighted by the committee as engaging
in indirect discrimination and these are
rules that for example
make a migrant spouse dependent on their
partner
or rules
which mean that if someone wants to
apply for refugee family reunion they
have to meet a certain minimum income
requirement
now these rules on their face may appear
to be gender-neutral but they have
particular gendered consequences
so women might find it more difficult
than men for example to meet minimum
income requirements because of gender
disadvantage in the labor market
and similarly um women who are placed or
who are forced into relationships of
dependency with an employer or a spouse
may face an increased risk of being
subject to violence
so the broader research project that i'm
involved with goes through states
migration laws in a much more
fine-grained way and identifies ways in
which those rules are unlawfully
discriminatory
we might though today be more interested
in how the cedaw committee offers
protections to refugees and those who
are in need of international protection
now the cedaw committee has produced a
general recommendation
on the gender related dimensions of
refugee status asylum nationality and
the statelessness of women
now general recommendations are an
interpretive tool
they're produced by the cedaw committee
um and they aim to unpack the core um
rights that are protected by the
convention they tell states essentially
how they need to meet their legal
obligations and they can be relied on by
individuals um to understand when and uh
their rights have been violated and what
the appropriate remedies may be
so i'm going to talk about the way that
the sea door committee has done some
normal filling now i've already
mentioned that the sea door committee's
definition
of discrimination against women um
includes gender-based violence
and i've said how this normal feeling
well was particularly important because
key instruments
in for example the international
protection regime don't
prohibit discrimination against women
but there are other gaps or absences in
the international protection regime
so you might be very well familiar
with the article 1a2 definition of a
refugee that can be found in the
convention relating to the status of
refugees
and it states that individuals are
refugees if they have a well-founded
fear of being persecuted because for
example of their nationality or their
political opinion
now whilst nationality political opinion
and race are all protected grounds in
the refugee convention there isn't a
ground that relates to sex gender sexual
orientation or gender identity and
instead individuals who seek to rely on
the refugee convention have to bring
their claim within the final ground that
set out in the article 1a2 definition
that of particular social group
now i can talk for hours and i'm not
going to do so now about the problems
with the jurisprudence on the psg ground
and in the q a we might want to think
about particular problems in the u.s
context with a very restrictive
interpretation that's used by u.s courts
and tribunals one which is very much out
of step with international law
what's really important for us today
though is the role that the cedaw
committee has taken um into arguing that
states need to take a gender-sensitive
approach to all of the convention
grounds not just the psg grant but for
example recognizing women's political
activism and women's political agency
and protecting for example feminist
resistance to domestic violence or
feminist resistance to trafficking as
political opinions and not just dealing
with those cases under the psg ground
and it's not just a gender-sensitive
approach to credibility that states are
required to take um it's about internal
relocation and all aspects of the
refugee convention definition as well
in addition to putting forward a
gender-sensitive approach to the um
refugee convention
the cedaw committee goes into a lot of
detail as to what refugee status
determination should look like for women
and this is important because this is
another gap in the article in that csr
so the refugee convention tells us an
article 1a2 who a refugee is
but the refugee convention doesn't tell
us how we should recognize refugees
doesn't tell us what rights refugees
have when they're going through status
determination do they have a right to a
lawyer for example and what particular
rights do vulnerable groups going
through this process require
now this general recommendation makes it
clear that protection seeking women
should have their claims determined by a
system which is informed in every
respect by a thorough understanding
of discrimination and persecution on the
grounds of sex and gender and the
impacts of that treatment
and specific examples of this gender
sensitive approach would be for example
requiring a woman to be interviewed
by a caseworker who is also a woman and
having a female interpreter present
it includes things like providing child
care and ensuring that victims of
torture and sexual violence are referred
to and receive appropriate psychosocial
support
so these protections are really
important to ensure that the gender
sensitive interpretation of the
convention is actually available to
women who go through rsd processes
the core protection though um
general recommendation 32 or this
particular interpretation offers
is that women can use cedaw and rely on
cedaw to argue that they should not be
returned to situations where they face
for example discrimination on the
grounds of sex or gender-based violence
and cedaw's protection from reform or
from this return is broader than the
protection that applies to refugees
under the refugee convention
so cedaw's expansive definition of
discrimination can be used to identify
unlawful discrimination against women at
every stage in their journey from
countries of origin to countries of
destination and beyond
and cedaw committee recommendations like
the one that i've just talked you
through when applied indivisibly
establishes a set of mostly reinforcing
obligations which requires states to
remedy discriminatory treatment against
women
there are however a number of failures
and a number of gaps and emissions in
the committee's reasoning
so when it comes to indirect
discrimination for example the committee
doesn't tell women how they can evidence
differential treatment do they have to
do so on the basis of statistical
evidence or not for example and
crucially the cedaw committee is silent
on questions of justification and this
is really important from a
discrimination law perspective because
states often assert um particular rights
as flowing from their sovereignty in the
cases of migration control they will
they will have kind of very broad
statements that um the prerogatives of
migration control requires things like
detention um deportation pushbacks or
variety of other practices now if these
practices have disproportionate impacts
on women the legal question that we have
to ask is whether these disproportional
impacts can be justified and we need the
committee to be really clear on the
circumstances in which states are
entitled to pursue those measures and
the circumstances where adverse effect
to use the language of u.s
discrimination law is not um justifiable
treatment and therefore the state should
change its policies
and i think if you're interested in kind
of following this line of argument
further the sea door committee has
produced a general comment um
specifically on trafficking and global
migration control
and this
has a number of really significant gaps
in it and essentially it reads more like
a policy statement than a legal tool
that individuals could use um if they
have been trafficked for example to
argue for their rights against states um
or for those involved in civil society
organizations to understand what for
example a process that's able to
identify victims of trafficking should
look like
i'm now going to move to the the kind of
second part of my research and discuss
cedaw committee jurisprudence
so this is about cases that are brought
to the committee
and cases can be brought by individuals
who are in countries which have signed
up to seedle's optional protocol
and for this research i reviewed
nine years worth of communications and i
identified 34 communications as
concerning states migration control
practices
and the majority of these communications
were found to be inadmissible and i'll
explain
why some of that was in a moment there
were only three cases where a breach was
found
now most of these cases came from just
one country in europe denmark and more
authors of communications were
represented by one man then came from
the remaining mostly european countries
all of these cases were the majority of
these cases concerned nor formal so the
protection of women who argued that they
should not be returned to countries
where they faced um discrimination
persecution and gender-based violence
now these findings are significant
um for a number of reasons the first i'm
going to highlight
is the fact that they do not represent
the breadth of the committee's standard
setting in relation to migration control
so both the committee's work on direct
discrimination and indirect
discrimination its protection of migrant
workers for example and its protections
for people who are experiencing or at
risk of gender-based violence much of
that is just absent from these
communications and instead what we get
if we look at siegel's work on migration
control is a data set which is
geographically skewed to particular
european countries and which is
substantively distorted
but there are two significant
deficiencies in the way that the
committee has approached issues around
migration
control and the first is around
its assessment of a communications
admissibility
and the difference between admissibility
and merits determination
and the second is that the committee
adopts such a deferential standard of
review in some of the cases it's called
upon to decide that effectively fails to
apply the obligations it has delineated
so when you bring a case before an
international court or tribunal you have
to show that you meet certain
admissibility requirements
you have to show um that you have for
example exhausted domestic remedies and
that the thing that you're complaining
about falls within the scope of the
relevant convention
so when courts or human rights treaty
bodies like the cedaw committee reviews
individual communications
the assessment it goes through is often
a two-stage assessment
first they have to ask themselves if a
complaint is admissible
and then second they move to considering
its merits has there been a violation of
the relevant
right that's protected or rights that
it's protected
now in the first set of cases that i've
reviewed the committee makes these
points
and decides these points um sequentially
and appropriately
in the second set of cases concerning
non-reformer the committee collapses
these two questions into each other and
what that does is it leaves individuals
who are concerned about refurma at risk
of return to situations where they might
be
experiencing persecution or serious
forms of gender-based violence
the second problem the committee has is
around the standard of review that it
applies how it scrutinizes states
reasoning in asylum determination
processes
and my concern here is a committee
adopts such a deferential standard of
review that it fails to protect um
individuals who seek to rely on its
obligations
so i'm going to talk about
these two
deficiencies in the analysis by drawing
on
four illustrative cases
um so
the first case that i want to talk about
is rsaa vs denmark
so rssa was a palestinian refugee
she was from syria and she obtained a
jordanian passport following her
marriage to a jordanian man
she had two children
and she claimed international protection
in denmark on the grounds that she had
experienced domestic violence and that
her children were at risk of forced
marriage
now all of these things um are protected
or should be um within the purview of
the sedor convention
her claim for asylum was however refused
primarily on credibility grounds and her
and her children's deportation was
arranged
so the cedaw committee first looked at
the admissibility of her complaint
and under the cedaw committee's optional
protocol article 42 uh communication is
admissible
if it is
properly founded and properly
substantiated
now the committee um reviewed her case
and found that her communication was
sufficiently substantiated she'd been
able to show them on a primo fascia
basis that has seed or protected rights
and had been violated
it then went on to consider the
substance of her asylum
claim essentially
on a case-by-case basis and applied the
correct merit standard of review which i
put on the slide in front of you
so the committee says that it's for the
authorities of states parties to the
convention to evaluate facts and
evidence on the application of national
law unless it can be established that
the evaluation was biased or based on
gender stereotypes that constitute
discrimination against women was clearly
arbitrary or amounted to a denial of
justice
so when it's looking at how states
determine asylum applications when how
the state approached our essays case
this is the standard of review that the
treaty body is applying
so the sea door committee looked at the
facts in her asylum claim and in
particular they looked at the way that
she had been deemed incredible they also
looked at the structural barriers that
she faced as a jordanian
individual but somebody who was of
palestinian origin so someone who was a
refugee and had that history um in the
country where that she experienced
gender-based violence
the committee held that she faced a real
personal and foreseeable risk that as a
woman who had knowingly fled her violent
husband and had fled jordan with her two
minor daughters and was at risk of
further gender-based violence
and the committee took her
intersectional approach to the
discrimination that she had faced in
jordan
and they found that denmark hadn't
accorded due weight to her status as a
palestinian refugee
now um earlier on i talked about general
recommendation 32 and i talked about the
standards that the committee has set for
how states should determine asylum
applications
and when it was applying the standard of
review
to rsa's case the committee found a
number of ways in which denmark had not
properly applied general recommendation
32.
essentially denmark had failed to meet
its obligations under cedaw um and the
return of rss
sorry rsaa and her children would breach
the convention
so what we have here is an example of
somebody who makes a claim for
international protection who argues that
they are a refugee under international
law
but whose claim
is not recognized by the state that
she's in
and who relies therefore on cedaw and
the seed or committee to prevent her
deportation to prevent her removal
and because her case involves
gender-based violence and because her
case requires the monitoring body to
take an intersectional approach to the
violence and discrimination that she
fears she goes to the cedaw committee
which as i hopefully have explained to
you in the introduction to this talk um
protects women who are refugees and
doesn't discriminate between the rights
that nationals and non-nationals should
have so should be an appropriate fora
for this kind of complaint and she's
successful and denmark cannot remove her
we don't know if she's recognized as a
refugee as a consequence of this
decision but we know that she's not
going to face or we hope that she's not
going to face deportation to jordan
now i want to contrast that case with
one that was decided just a few months
later
and it also concerned a case against
denmark and it concerned a very similar
factual situation
and so this time kia was someone who had
been resident
in denmark for her childhood and she was
tricked into leaving the country and
forced into marriage
she was subjected to domestic and sexual
violence for 11 years
and she eventually managed to escape and
to return to denmark where she made a
claim for refugee protection
and again um her history as someone who
had palestinian origins
and the intersectional nature
of the violence and discrimination that
she experienced in jordan were key parts
of her claim
but the committee didn't reach the same
decision in her case that it reached in
the previous one i discussed they found
her communication inadmissible and what
they did was collapse the admissibility
and merits reasoning they applied to her
and to her case a much higher standard
of review
her account was unsubstantiated because
she couldn't show that her treatment was
biased or based on gender stereotypes or
arbitrary
so what these two cases show us
is that the committee approached the
situation confronted by two women who
both faced quite
similar and disturbing levels of
domestic and sexual violence but in two
substantively different ways
and in the second situation the
committee collapses two distinct
questions the question of admissibility
and the question of whether a right had
been violated in such a way as to
preclude the merits being properly
considered
and what that meant was that whilst rss
rsaa and her children were protected
from deportation
kia and her children were not
so having exhausted the asylum
determination process in denmark they
risked uh reformal and potentially to
gender-based violence and other forms of
serious harm
they'd gone to an international
soft court to have their rights
vindicated
and instead
those rights were not properly
considered
so that's the first failure that i want
to highlight about the way that the
cedaw committee approaches um some of
the cases that come before it
and i want to use two more cases now to
show another failure
and this is similar to the first point
i've made but it is analytically
distinct it concerns the standard of
review again and it concerns how the
cedaw committee approaches migrants
women's rights not in the abstract
when it's looking at general
recommendations but when confronted with
alleged violations
so i have two cases um that i want to
discuss uh with you and i want to do
these cases um to chart the contours of
a particular kind of responsibility
deficit
so the first case is from a few years
ago now from 2013
um it concerned um a woman who fled
burundi
and claimed refugee protection on the
grounds of political persecution
she was a member of an opposition party
and had been involved as a political
activist in a number of events and
demonstrations
now while she was attempting to escape
political violence she was raped by more
than one perpetrator at knifepoint
she went through the asylum process and
her claim was rejected
now she then proceeds to take her case
to the cedaw committee to argue that she
should not be returned to burundi
and her case is found to be inadmissible
but for a very striking reason
so emien disclosed the sexual violence
that she had been subject to
but she didn't describe that violence in
her asylum interview as being
discrimination
instead she believed that it was
coincidental that she had been raped
now the cedaw committee said that
because she phrased that part of her
claim in that way the state party in
this case denmark didn't have the
opportunity to consider her allegations
of gender-based violence
now this is a really astonishing
decision for the committee to reach
because what they're saying is and they
say it very clearly on the face of this
case
that describing having been raped at
knife point by three men but not
defining that treatment to sex
discrimination is not sufficient to
raise that treatment in your asylum
claim
her case was inadmissible and we don't
know whether or not she was subject and
to return
this case is interesting because it has
a really strong dissenting opinion
and that dissenting opinion was written
by someone called dubrav kasimonovic
who went on to become the un's special
reporter
against violence and women its causes
and consequences
and she rooted her dissenting opinion in
general recommendation 19 on
gender-based violence
arguing that it was a matter of
customary international law and
international criminal law as well as
the sea door committee's own work that
such sexual violence was discrimination
against women and should have been
considered properly in the case
so men is one example of the committee
failing to apply its own standards in a
really clear and concrete and easy to
identify way but i want to draw on a
more recent case to make this point as
well
and because i'm talking to you from
europe um i want to use this case to
talk about some of the issues that are
being confronted by refugees in europe
at the moment
and in particular um their return
from one european country to another
where they've claimed asylum in one
country but traveled within the european
union
so um at the moment within the european
union there is a system whereby an
individual who claims asylum in one
country but then travels on and seeks
international or other protection in
another and if they are identified as
having done that will be returned under
european union law and there are very
few exceptions to this return there are
some that may be based on the family
reunion and but in general this way
of uh it's called responsibility sharing
but it's certainly not that um is a way
of containing refugees um in the first
country that they claim asylum and uh
has a disproportionate impact on
countries like italy for example and
spain and who receive large numbers of
individuals seeking international
protection from across the mediterranean
and so abdi osman was someone who
fled
truly horrific
torture and violence in somalia
she was kidnapped by a member of
al-shabab she was forced to marry the
person who kidnapped her her father
tried to protect her and he was murdered
in that incident she was subjected to
torture and sexual violence over a
number of years
she became pregnant
uh three times um and two of those
pregnancies were ended in a forced
abortion and the third
child who was born was taken from her
she managed to escape and made the
incredibly
difficult dangerous and a legalized
journey to italy
where she was granted subsidiary
protection
now in italy the treatment that she
received did not meet the standards set
out in general recommendation 32.
ms absentman was homeless for a number
of years
she was detained and she wasn't offered
protections as a survivor of sexual
violence or a survivor of torture
and she certainly wasn't offered any
kind of psychosocial support or
assistance and she claimed that she
should have been recognized as a refugee
um but instead she was granted a lesser
form of protection complementary
protection in the european union
she formed a relationship
and she wished to move and join her
husband um in switzerland another
country in the european union
she did so and she made a claim for
asylum there
and that claim was refused and she was
returned under the dublin iii regulation
the system where individuals are
returned to the first country they
claimed in to italy
and when we talk about returns and
deportation and that language often
sanitize processes which are incredibly
violent um and harmful to the
individuals concerned and we might be
familiar with the violence of
deportation in the sense of individuals
being handcuffed and compelled into
immigration detention or on a plane this
was a different type of violence because
ms abdul-obsman was driven to the border
she was given a small amount of euros in
cash and she was left in a car park
and she was there in that car park with
another group of refugees and she lived
on the streets for a period of days she
wasn't told where to go she wasn't told
what to do she wasn't given any type of
support or assistance by the state
and she slowly made her way back to her
husband
to switzerland and she became pregnant
again and again she faces return to
italy
her health by this point had
deteriorated quite significantly
she brings a claim to the sea door
committee to try and opt out of this
european system of compelling people to
return from one country to another
and she does so on the basis that she's
been subject to discrimination and
violence not only in her country of
origin
but also in italy where she has been
mistreated now on two occasions
the cedaw committee
have the general recommendation that i
talked to you through in front of them
and ms abdi osman's legal representative
takes them through
all of the rights and protections that i
described to you and in particular the
support that should be accorded to
sexual violence
um unaccountably the committee however
stated it is for the sovereign state
party to determine the nature structure
and procedures of its own asylum system
and moreover they said it was unclear
that ms abdi osman
would face no specific indications that
she would not be afforded protection in
italy
and it reached that decision despite the
fact that as i've explained to you she
didn't get the protection or health care
that she was entitled to under the seed
or convention on not one but two
occasions so she can point to two
examples in the past where her rights
have been protected and even doing so is
not sufficient to offer her protection
from return
her case
was denied so this is another example of
the cedaw committee just not applying
not enforcing the standards that it has
identified as being necessary to protect
refugee women from discrimination
and from a legal perspective this is
really problematic because the committee
roots the general recommendation 32
obligations
in that definition of discrimination
against women that i started this
seminar with
so this isn't presented as being you
know an optional set of protections that
individuals um may be entitled to the
sea door committee is saying that this
is required by states as a matter of
international law
and yet
when women seek to rely on those
standards the cedaw committee does not
vindicate them
and what the decision in ms abdulsman's
case does is leave a woman who has a
significant set of health problems as a
result of torture and sexual violence to
be deported with a newborn baby to a
country which has repeatedly failed to
meet the standards the committee has set
now these two views that i've given you
are not anomalous but representative of
others in which the committee's adoption
of a general recommendation makes little
discernible difference to its
adjudication of communications that are
brought to it
so i'm sure you'll be very pleased to
know that i'm reaching the conclusions
part of this paper
um i think and as i've hoped in the
first couple of slides in this
presentation to show you that cedaw is
well placed to respond to discrimination
against women that's experienced in the
context of migration control
and there are a number of reasons for
this
the definition of discrimination is
capacious as i've said it covers both
direct and indirect discrimination
including that which is violent whether
experienced in the public or private
domain
the committee takes a broad
effects-based approach to jurisdiction
and its beneficiaries which enables it
in theory to hold states responsible for
their extra territorial and
discriminatory conduct
and in its general recommendations the
committee has capitalized on this
advantageous positioning
interpreting the convention robustly and
impugning as discriminatory a range of
laws and practices
it's also as i hope to have highlighted
required states to make gender-sensitive
determination procedures that apply
gender-sensitive interpretations of core
facets of the international protection
regime such as the article 182
definition of a refugee
and more importantly it enables or urges
states to increase women's ability to
migrate safely and access protection
lawfully
there are however significant flaws in
the reasoning that the committee has
employed in a number of instances
and i focused in its adjudication
elements on non-reformal and the
protection that should be accorded to
women who claim refugee protection
it's of concern that so few cases are
brought to the committee alleging
discrimination and migration control
when the committee has engaged in such
standard setting in this area
and it's of concern that a number of
states who have the laws and practices
that the committee impunes are not being
challenged before the cedaw committee by
individuals affected by them
but when communications are brought the
committee's reasoning is disappointing
and frequently unprincipled
and this is the case um notwithstanding
the fact that in some of its decisions
the committee has given adjudicative
expression to its commitment to respond
to multiple and intersecting forms of
discrimination and inequality and i
think the rssa case i mentioned before
is an example of that it wasn't just the
case that she was a woman who was at
risk of gender discrimination she was
also unable to access equal protection
of the law because she was a palestinian
refugee so that's an intersectional
approach being taken to the violence and
the lack of protection available to her
however there are a number of other
cases in the data set that i examined
where the committee takes an overly
deferential approach to questions
around state power and state's migration
control functions
and this deferential approach seems to
have two elements to it either a failure
to differentiate between admissibility
and merits
or a failure to apply its own legal and
normative standards
and in both of these examples women
complaining of discriminatory treatment
are exposed to the risk of reform
so there's a wealth of research on the
cedaw committee so love day hodson for
example has said the committee has been
unable to establish much of a voice on
the asylum claims of vulnerable women
and alternatively bassat khali katherine
costello and stuart cullingham have said
the committee has taken identity a
tentative and deferential approach
i hope that you will have seen by now
that my conclusions are much more
scathing of the committee's actions in
this regard i think that their reasoning
is unprincipled and as a result of that
women's rights in the context of refugee
protection go unrealized
the core kind of conclusion that i'm
reaching in this research is that the
committee needs to eliminate all forms
of discrimination
it has to delineate the obligations with
clarity and precision and then it must
hold states responsible for violating
the standards it has itself set
so i appreciate that that was um 45
minutes that was quite dense from a
legal perspective and that some of you
may not be lawyers or have a background
in international law and so if you have
any questions at all about any of the
material that i've covered i'd be
delighted to discuss them with you
further
i have a question can you see me
yes
yes please do go ahead and i can hear
you wonderfully too okay great um
so just thinking really practically
about the us context is the us one of
the countries that is not a signatory of
cdaw
and i'm also thinking about um how trump
also removed domestic violence as
um like as as characteristic of a
particular kind of group-based
discrimination i'm just wondering if you
can speak
more to the u.s context here
yes um so i uh you can there is
something called the uh united nations
treaty depository and you can i can
share a link to that in the chat in a
moment and you can look up uh which
states have signed and ratified cedaw
and i'm afraid the u.s is a real outlier
in this regard in being one of the few
states that has not done that
um now as i understand it under u.s
immigration law individuals can seek
withholding from removal on the basis of
cat the convention against torture
and so the convention against torture is
very similar to cedaw in that it's a
united
nations legal instrument that defines a
particular kind of wrong
and then
protects um individuals from either
experiencing that in the country that
they're in or being returned to that
and so the the u.s asylum system does
engage with a very limited way with
international law with the refugee
convention and with cat but it doesn't
um
engage with cedaw in the way that i've
described
could you repeat the second part of your
question oh i guess just the other one
was that
i guess i'm just thinking about that the
always the tension between international
law and like sovereignty questions right
i'm thinking specifically about the
trump administration's decision to not
count domestic violence as uh like under
the definition of group-based
discrimination um
and
and how that changed like the ability
for women to make claims for asylum
um
and then i'm thinking about like
specific
you know some of the rumblings in the
european union about uh not just
reservations to these clauses but the
ways in which they're just flouting them
you know entirely um under the name you
know under the discourse of crisis
or things like that so i'm just
wondering if you can speak to like you
know the way that maybe some of the um
deferential
uh posturing of cedaw has to do with
playing this game of trying to keep
countries sort of on board on a
day-to-day
basis does that make sense
i'm going to try and answer each of
those in turn and do let me know if i
don't do so fully
so the first one was around the specific
jurisprudence in the us around
particular social groups and i mentioned
earlier that the us was an outlier
in taking a very limited
approach to the definition of what is a
particular social group
and seeking um through various means
to exclude women who are at risk of
domestic violence from that definition
but also individuals who are at risk of
gang-related violence as well
the common denominators here being that
it's violence perpetrated by a non-state
actor
and there are issues around how you
define the particular social group and
the u.s is very restrictive
approach to that question but then
there's a second set of questions about
how you identify whether or not the
state is willing to protect individuals
from particular forms of violence and
again within the us jurisprudence as i
understand it there has been attempts um
to significantly um increase what an
applicant has to do to show that the
state is not able to protect them
and the reason why i'm hedging all my
comments here is that this is very
contested at the moment um that these
cases are being litigated by wisdom
forwards and there have been some quite
notable successes in pushing back
against um some of these approaches and
nevertheless i think that the kind of
consistent strand in u.s jurisprudence
is a failure to recognize that women who
are fleeing gender-based violence
um are refugees um both on the member of
a particular social group ground but
also really importantly potentially on
the political opinion ground as well
i've come across one uh case uh which
some wonderful students mine from last
year shared which was a us case where
resistance to domestic violence feminist
resistance domestic violence was
interpreted as a political opinion um
and that's
something that has been litigated quite
successfully in other jurisdictions um
particularly for example um in new
zealand and also within the eu
now
if the u.s were to sign and ratify cedaw
and if it were to use cedaw as an
interpretative tool um we might expect
some improvements in that jurisprudence
um but you alluded to a separate set of
problems which are those currently faced
within the european union and council of
europe at the moment
and these don't go just a seed or they
go to something called the istanbul
convention which is the council of
europe convention on violence and
discrimination against women
and this convention is really important
because it embeds a lot of what cedor
has done within the council of europe
but it also has specific articles in it
which protect migrant and refugee women
including by offering them migration
statuses
and by ensuring some of the things that
i've talked about in this talk
are incorporated into states and
national law like gender sensitive
interpretations of the refugee
convention
um now a number of states have attempted
to put reservations into those treaties
or have unsigned them um all
states have taken quite a
um
negative approach to the convention
they've said a series of things about
the way that convention protects um
intersectionally on the grounds of
sexual orientation for example and use
that as a pretext and for not offering
protection from violence and i think
this needs to be seen um within a
broader um response to
authoritarianism and not just
authoritarianism in europe but how we
think about the role of international
law in
responding or countering um some of the
gendered impacts of the rise of
authoritarianism in certain states and
that's something
that many women who are being activists
in poland at the moment around changes
to law and abortion for example
are having to contest on the streets
while we talk about it in this classroom
thank you
i have some quite a few
questions so one is that for example
um
is there once the cedaw has given
his determination is there a way to
appeal
then the other one is that
um
i mean given the difference that they
have been reaching some of the cases uh
could that be explained for example in
the uh initial
representation that these women have had
in
maybe like access
initially to
like a
lawyer or to or that they are aware of
how they can bring the case
and then the other question that i have
is that
how is this
committee form and then for how long i
mean is it that
some
some of the
people
that are part of the committee basically
have some views or they have
uh evolve over time
as well
so on appeal no if the committee
declares a decision inadmissible there's
no way to appeal that now you may be
able to bring a case before another
international body another human rights
treaty body for example like the
committee that oversees the convention
on the elimination of race
discrimination or before the cat
committee
now um you're not allowed to bring cases
before multiple
human rights treaty bodies because
that's precluded by admissibility
requirements but individuals do bring
cases often to more than one
um i think one of the things that that's
interesting to look at is why some human
rights treaty bodies
scrutinize state action more than others
and there is um kind of an emerging
strand in the research that indicates
that the cat committee is much more
robust in protecting individuals rights
when they allege that they are run the
risk of being refulled
and that in comparison um the iccpr the
human rights committee
and the sea door committee take a much
less
robust approach and i think one of the
things you might want to think about
although perhaps how you would design
this research as an interesting question
is why committees which have quite
similar standards of review why some
committees are much more deferential to
states than others are
um i think with cat um the convention
against torture's definition of torture
is very narrow in comparison with for
example cedaw's definition of
gender-based violence
and so it may be that
its precision and its focus and that
narrowness enables the cat committee to
take a much more robust approach to
states whereas because cedaw potentially
offers much broader panoply of rights um
it's therefore less
assertive and enforcing them i mean we
would have to think about whether that
was the correct and principled legal
approach but that may be one reason why
the sea door committee is more
deferential
the other thing i wrote down was
membership so yes members serve for
particular periods of time they are
nominated i can't remember i've stopped
my head how long i'm going to say five
years but we can check
the the relevant documents so it will be
set out in the convention for how many
years
um individuals are nominated by states
to serve
but when you are there um you serve in
your individual capacity as an expert
so you should not put forward for
example your state's views on any
particular problem you sit as an
independent individual
who's hopefully either legally informed
or legally rooted or has that background
that would enable you to interpret the
convention correctly
i'm sorry i missed the third part of
your question
no so i was thinking if
um yeah the
the so
how they're treating the cases will
differ either because
their own background or that they're
representing or or
because it happens to have
a composition that basically
is more harsh than
than others um
in certain cases so i think that's a i
think that's a really interesting
hypothesis but i don't think that um
i i suspect that it that that's not the
reason simply because all human rights
treaty bodies have very similar
processes by which experts
are nominated by states and then serve
on committees and the fact that i mean
how do
the women access
i mean help in order to bring their
cases to the cedaw is that right legal
aid yes you mentioned that
so again that um will depend on each
state's um national provisions so within
the european union a number of states
and the uk obviously not remember the
european union now and do have
provisions that enable individuals to
receive legal advice and representation
that's free of charge um and even when
that's not available there are a number
of not-for-profit organizations who also
provide that assistance
um interestingly a number of the cases i
reviewed individuals who bring those
cases representing themselves
um and
so the quality of legal advice i think
is a real issue i think you're
absolutely right and pointing to that as
being one of the reasons why some of
these cases are not successful
when they should be on their face
and then i imagine that once you um
start the process
then i mean like the case that you shown
that because it has not been said in a
specific way so therefore
it has a certain consequence as well
so
now that may be a problem
within some courts and tribunals but it
shouldn't be before a human rights
treaty bodies who's um who don't see
individuals so you don't litigate
directly you don't argue in geneva or
new york for example you don't stand at
a lectern and explain how your rights
have been violated a lot of these these
cases are just decided on the basis of
materials which are submitted to the
committee which the committee then
reviews
um and because the committee's
procedures around evidence and how it
makes decisions are fairly flexible um i
think you are going to be kind of less
disadvantaged as an individual
representing yourself before human
rights treaty bodies potentially than
before for example the inter-american
court or the european court of human
rights
um
it's interesting as well that in a
number of the cases from denmark legal
representation was highlighted as being
a problem
um and i think the committee is rightly
concerned that that cases are just being
brought to the cedaw committee um where
the individual consent is
is not receiving the quality of legal
advice and representation that they
should i think i'll leave it that part
there
this is a really specific question
catherine um why do you pick nine year
for your data sets
um
do you know that that's
simply the case that i was looking for a
range of communications that would be
both before and after the adoption of
the particular general recommendations
that i was interested in
so in the last decade we have general
recommendations adopted on trafficking
on asylum and refugee status and
gender-based violence and so i wanted a
number of communications to come from
before and after the dates that those
recommendations were adopted to see what
the adoption of a recommendation what
difference that made to particular cases
um and so nine years just enabled me to
do that and enabled me just to read the
kind of requisite volume of
communications to be able to reach
decisions you could go back further
fairly obviously and all of the
um conclusions that i have started to
set out to you are premised on the fact
that that's a limited data set nine
years worth of cases
going back sorry to the some of the
point that i mentioned i mean do you
know there how many times the committees
change as well i mean there are like if
if they were to be like five years so
sort of see
two or three
sort of set of uh
of committee just
with i mean just to test the hypothesis
that
some composition might be sort of
harsher to other ones
of the community
so i think that that information must be
publicly available you know how long
people served when people joined and
when people left i think the two cases
that i showed that concerned um
individuals who were palestinian
refugees who claimed asylum in denmark
which were decided so close to each
other indicates that it's not the
composition of the committee that's
necessarily the problem
and because one would imagine that it
was
not necessarily entirely the same group
of people sitting on the committee but
that there would be quite a significant
overlap between the individual sitting
yeah that's certainly an avenue that i
could and should pursue so thank you for
suggesting
any more questions on the
in the room or
on the
in zoom
no
i have a question that's okay
because i i'm aware that i'm
predominantly potentially speaking to an
audience um who are based in the u.s or
potentially who are u.s citizens and are
familiar with u.s immigration
nationality law um i would be interested
in to what extent um you find arguments
based on international or interesting or
compelling or relevant to your research
and interests because if you're within
europe kind of geographically rather
than politically these are arguments
that you're very familiar with and that
you would engage in potentially even
before
domestic tribunals um but i'm aware that
that's not the case potentially for a
number of you who may be involved in
activism or litigation or research where
international law potentially seems
quite removed or not relevant to the
types of arguments that you're
interested in making
i could i i'm not a legal scholar but i
am a migration and border enforcement
scholar um and i think i can speak first
just as a us citizen to the way in which
i think international law is still
like broadly read as like an
overstepping of sovereignty i think that
actually probably is the
sort of
sentiment on the street and i think that
that's growing in europe too right but
i'm also uh i but my research takes
place in north africa and it's right
africa
where international law is often viewed
as sort of just an extension of a
colonial like imposition um
and particularly around issues of gender
right like you have
such a different such different
interpretations of what constitutes
violence
um sort of uh
you know
all those like all that bundle of issues
around gender and then also
you know for thinking about
international courts you know we're
thinking about you know
who gets prosecuted in those courts
they're mostly like postcolonial leaders
and so there is a lot of resistance i
think there's both at the state level a
diplomatic and geopolitical um
motivation to participate in these
conventions but there's also like a deep
seated
suspicion and resistance against them to
the to the you know
to the end that some of the african
countries have formed their own court
right like so
yeah so it's complicated i think
i mean one of the cases i excluded from
the sample was a woman who got
recognized as a refugee in the uk but
then brought a case against libya for
the gender-based violence that she had
experienced um there um as a feminist
activist so i i would say that it's it's
not entirely the case that international
law is kind of viewed
with suspicion in those instances
because this was an example of somebody
who when they got to a jurisdiction of
safety one of the first things they did
was bring a case against the country
that they had fled from to
argue that their international legally
protected rights had been violated and
interestingly that case was entirely
successful and so
that kind of speaks to your research but
i think it also
reflects on some of the things that i've
been talking about which is when
somebody is recognized as a refugee and
they're bringing a case about the state
that they have fled from the cedaw
committee can recognize that and find
the violations
but when individuals are bringing cases
against refugee receiving states for
violations of their rights um the senate
committee is less able to
to recognize that and to vindicate those
rights in the migration control context
yeah the other thing is that uh yeah
i guess
i mean when when you ask
the question to the
people attending
this seminar
probably your
i mean it's not representative of what
the majority of the
u.s
people are thinking about
because
yeah as you said in other countries you
think
i mean international law sort of
uh
protecting you or some of the the last
resort of
of some
of the
protection of rights in then is thought
more like an invasion of their own
sovereignty
that matches my intuition as well that i
think a lot of people that are
sort of
already have an anti-migrant
anti-refugee disposition also have a
deep skepticism of
international law writ large and so
i think sort of
it seems to me that like in at least the
u.s political context that
i don't think
international migration law is like
seen as a lower likely to change a lot
of things i guess
well if i could follow up to you on the
libya example i think like from the
north african context the fact that that
women's case was adjudicated against
libya and not against you know the
european union or italy for initiating
the pushbacks you know like pushbacks or
arming
you know uh libyan defense or militias
or you know all of that like creating
those particular contexts i think sort
of under you know like underscores the
point um that people feel like a
suspicion right of international law as
still really um serving european
interests or euro american interests
over
you know over global interests or or
being selective about those maybe would
be and i think yeah i i would agree with
the broad thrust of that analysis and i
think that the case i talked about
towards the end ms abdiozman's case is a
perfect example of that because a
european system which was predicated in
deterrence which was predicated in
containing refugees in particular areas
in europe um which as i said when i i
kind of went through the facts of that
case in a lot of detail because i wanted
to really make the point that on two
occasions all of these rights protected
by cedaw had been violated and yet the
committee says we have no evidence that
if she's going to be returned she would
face those violations okay what do they
need then actually under those
circumstances what possibly could she
have presented to them
and so we might see that case as an
example of migration control imperatives
within the european union and this
particular eu model of returning
individuals to the first country where
they claimed asylum being vindicated by
the committee in this respect because
there's no challenge available to her
and she can't or you know it's very
difficult for her to do so through
european union mechanisms and the one
mechanism we might think should be
available to her as someone who's
experienced sexual violence and torture
and gender-based violence cedor the
committee doesn't take the role um that
it's that has been given to it in
international law and i think that's
really troubling
when i discuss this research i'm
normally discussing it in countries
where individuals have the opportunity
to use the mechanisms that i'm talking
about
and so it's very different when i speak
to you because it's much more abstract
potentially depending on where you might
go and work
after your studies here um
and so that often kind of presents a
particular kind of conflict for me
because a lot of the time i will point
to particular things in states and say
look this the sea dog committee has
impugned as discriminatory so when i
talk to legal activists i'll say why
don't you bring a case um you know use
really clear recommendations on this
point
and you have for example a group of
individuals who require protection so
you should consider this international
remedy so on the one hand sometimes when
i'm talking to audiences i say use the
remedy but it has this problem whereas
when i'm talking to you i can't even say
use the remedy i'm painting a picture of
an international regime and that has
potentially only tangential interest to
you or tangential impact on the work
that you may be doing
there is a
question on the chat about um
how
uh if
uh and if the gender and kovite 19
guidance from international bodies has
resulted in any shifting policies
because
the problems on the ground on gender are
very real
ask about how guys initiated policies
yes um i
don't
know
a seed or rooted
answer to that question
other than that the protection the
convention protects equal access to
health care and maternity services um
for example and there has been
successful litigation women's rights um
for example to
um to uh healthcare around
having healthy children
was
denied particularly on intersexual
grounds such as race and being a member
of an indigenous group there's kind of
some really interesting jurisprudence of
the sea door committee on that doesn't
relate to covet 19 though
the only specific guidance i can think
of would be from unhcr which has like a
data portal um where it's produced kind
of an analysis of um either restrictive
or non-restrictive measures adopted by
states um in relation to covid19 because
we're aware that the pandemic is used by
states as an opportunity to kind of
entrench or further entrench policies um
of immobility
um i i agree that that presents a series
of issues around gender in particular in
relation to gender-based violence but i
can't think of a kind of clear
documental source that that i can point
you to
um i've got sarah's question now and
they're characteristically challenging
so thank you for that
um
so
have there been any um
interaction between the committee's
reasoning the european court of human
rights and other treaty bodies
and there has been so the european court
of human rights
regularly refers to the work of the
cedaw committee in its cases on violence
and discrimination against women
and there are kind of certain key cases
such as opus versus turkey for example
um where the court defers to the sea
door committee's definition of violence
and discrimination against women and
says that cedaw is the specialist legal
regime that regional courts should turn
to
when adjudicating on for example article
14 nondiscrimination cases involving
gender-based violence
has there been any interaction
here when we think about challenges to
dublin returns because you're right abdi
osman
is very similar to a number of cases
where individuals have gone to the
european court of human rights to
challenge their removal from one eu
country to another and what they've
normally done is relied on article three
which is the prohibition of torture and
human and degrading treatment
um and we might want to think about why
ms abdi osman um brought a case to the
sea door committee and not to the
european court of human rights and i
don't know the the answer to that um i
think that's it's interesting to think
about if you have more than one
international court or tribunal to go to
why you would choose a un treaty body
and not um a regional court
um it may well be that the court's
reasoning is so restrictive when it
comes to things like dublin returns that
she thought that the cedaw committee
because her case was was so um
involved gender-based violence in every
point of her
her journey
and was so kind of uh it's almost hard
to approach it without that kind of
non-discrimination gender-based violence
lens that she thought the sea dog
committee would would vindicate her her
rights more than the european court um
would do
but you're absolutely right to point to
those cases at the european court of
justice um and the european court of
human rights um and obviously um mss is
one and tarakal is another where you see
the two courts engaged in a kind of kind
of transnational conversation about the
circumstances in which individuals can
be returned to either italy
or greece and the treatment that they
would face there the committee does not
draw on any of that discussion and it
does recount kind of paragraph after
paragraph of kind of ngo evidence about
the treatment of asylum seekers in italy
but then it doesn't again link that to
its general recommendation um on the
treatment of asylum seekers and refugees
so again there's this mismatch
and i would agree entirely that it
returns to italy um violations are only
um very rarely found
in comparison with returns to greece
although the standard of treatment was
quite similar in the two cases
okay so
thank you very much
dr briddick so if you join me as well
and
so hopefully at another time we might be
able to have you here
around and
this is our last seminar for the
fall and we'll see you back in the
spring next year thank you very much